ست قمار عباس من ضمن الاشياء التي ثارت
عندما كان الرئيس قبل ان اكمل سؤالي ربما
نشاهد على الشاشه الان الصوره لعمران خان
وهو ينقل ربما من قبل المسعفين بعد ان تمت
اصابته كما ذكرنا الاصابه يبدو انها في
القدم ولكن همم هذه صوره له همم عندما نقل
الى مستشفى في لاهور بعد ان اصيب حريسه
طبعا قضى يبدو في هذه العمليه ومنفذ
العمليه ايضا همم قتل على ما يبدو هذه
المعلومات التي لدينا حتى الان
وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه هي التي نقلت انه
قتل كنا شاهدناه قبل قليل همم يرتدي قميص
الاسود والناس تحيط به وتمسك به ولكن يبدو
ان هو تم قتله ولكن رئيس الوزراء السابق
انصاف عمران خان همم حالته الصح على حسب
ما ورد الان همم ما زالت يعني محل تساؤل
ولكن يبدو انه نجى من عمليه الاغتيال
الاصابه في قدمه هذه اخر صوره له كما
تشاهدو